hello there reject nation we got andrew
gordon with us today yeah to drop
stellar easter eggs and references with
no visual aids
cause that's how we roll
hey john hey so we're gonna watch
episode five of cobra kai it's like
eminem said you could rhyme orange with
anything i just did that with five
anyway we're gonna
check this out if you can hit that like
button sweet
if you could subscribe and click that
notification bell even better full
length watch along where you sync up
with the time code for cobra kai or over
at our patreon page become a superject
today by checking out everything over
there lastly thanks to the boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights
they do not know martial arts so we
bully them a lot that's right bully them
help edit
cut away
roll that intro
[Music]
my past behavior was
inexcusable all i can say now is
i'm truly sorry
does johnny know about any of this but
if you don't get off my property right
now i swear to god your dad is pissed
who is that guy
i have no idea he looks like a
highlander
if cobra kai wins the all valley
you two are done teaching
for good it's not gonna happen because
you're not gonna win now get the hell
out of here
it's terror he's like i don't get this
gun so much anger
this is my dojo as much as it is
unless you want to crammed up your ass
sideways you better take off after your
bridge partner
if your enemies do something to mess
with you
or laugh in your face take all that
anger and store it
because you're gonna need it when the
time comes
rajo load oh damn he's taking over
chris looked a little doubtful though
you're just gonna go to danny and be
like i made a big mistake and after i
beat barnes i never saw silver again
until today the year after our title
fight they put you straight through to
the finals it's [ __ ]
clearly never saw part three
i've seen his methods i know how his
warped mind works
the game has changed and we need to
change with it
which is why i need to take over our
students training from now on ooh ugh
they strike first you strike firster
yeah well i'm not going to play defense
all day i'll tell you that it worked
against silver and you remember barely
look we both know if we fought ten times
i had to beat you nine we have fought
ten times gentlemen i'm afraid i'm gonna
have to ask you to keep it down shut the
[ __ ] up
we never fought to the finish
what that's not what you want you honey
to finish the fight why not you think
you beat me again prove it
oh god
you and me tournament style first three
points wins
oh god and takes over the kids training
oh oh no this is not the
time
ah
30 minutes the baseball diamond
sundown on the sparring
guys what the
the [ __ ] f
turned businessman had a few ups and
downs but still turned out pretty rich
not much dirt other than some toxic
waste scandal in borneo damn look at his
hair how'd you even find out his name i
took a picture at the dojo then found an
old facial recognition beta test and
tweaked the code to make it compatible
with htic
i love it when you talk nerdy hey
i like the new hue
purple's the color of the crown chakra
you know
[Laughter]
yeah that's what i was going for so
huh
samia's eat at lunch specifically this
one
let's put our butts together
yo
you guys won't believe this since i got
drunk and went on a twitter rant
i believe everything except for the part
where he knows how to tweet
[Laughter]
yes
so this is real sensei and sensei are
going to throw down
cool
our daughter just sent me this
anything you want to tell me
what happened
terry silver happened
he's a certified whack job for my
password just come back to cobra county
another one
are there any other cobra kai's from
capacity are gonna come out of the
woodwork and destroy our lives mike
barnes
well
i can't say that for sure
set up
you know it just so i'm clear you're not
actually going to fight him right of
course not i'm sure he woke up just as
hungover as i did and realizes how
stupid this is a training montage right
now
wow
he's really going for it
punch dance it out johnny
that was a deleted scene
oh really yeah yeah
[Laughter]
whoa
that's right
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
go to jail for that man yeah this has
assaulted that guy
[Laughter]
hey johnny we both said some things we
regret i um sorry if i offended you no
don't apologize chose weakness
oh that's your arcs guys you must learn
to apologize
i had a bit of a rough night
makes sense
i saw johnny's tweets
everybody at school's talking about the
fight oh great
oh jesus your mom told me about the
birthday party it seems you're the one
doing the instigating now come on
compared to what tori's done that was
nothing i get that but you know we don't
believe in aggression that's not how we
act maybe that's not how you act
but i can make my own decisions
yeah
ooh
hate bishop the three d's
desire
devotion and discipline
first two i can't give you nice
the last one i can
but you have to be willing to receive it
are you all right
chimney stance
chris are you so upset man
i think you and i need to have a little
chat
it sucks we can't give a beat down
before the tournament
just because we can't fight doesn't mean
we can't get a little payback
they're gonna put milk in their lockers
i make like i'm gonna walk into it again
the last second i slip under shoulder
check under the balls take him to the
mat
so if you win we just train eagle fang
there's no miyagido you got a pontiac
but
what if i
don't want to stop learning miyagido
oh god
what the hell you saying you want him to
win no
i guess the way i see it no matter who
wins nobody wants somebody always wins
no matter what ancient philosophical
[ __ ] larusa's been feeding you
okay sensei
well good luck right
guys don't fight even though i kind of
want to see it
i'm
i thought if we talked together we could
make the kids stronger
[Music]
maybe they could end on a perfect tie
try to put aside the past
that's neat similar memories but
different times when they were attend
for my students
for my daughter
fighting him is the only way to move
forward
and if i'm wrong
i just hope that you'll forgive me
guys
bring us whatever bottle scotch your
boss has stashed for special occasions
you don't have to do i know
i'm just better than you
i'm talking about robbie keane
you never told me his father was johnny
lawrence now you've got him and the rest
of the kids wrapped up in all your old
drama and if you're not careful
it's gonna take cobra guy down all over
again yeah you're good terry you were
right about me john
i was living a lot
i lost who i was along the way and all
my hair ties focus on our students
we do that everything else will fall
into place
larusso will have to shut down miyagido
johnny lawrence
will rue the day he ever left kobe guy
what do you say dave he is so good
i say
we've got a victory in our future
[ __ ] oh boy that's silver man he is
awesome he's a great actor yeah
he's
something else
had two shops closed for the day
hey
damn that phone break makes sense damn
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] guys this is way too far
whoa what are they gonna tattoo on him
knowing that no fighting rules
you gonna do the mike tyson thing on his
face
oh no
gotta cut his hawk
off oh they're gonna like shave his
whole head yep i want what's best for
them what's best for them
is miyagido
and they're fighting you is the only way
i could get there then let's just get
this done
[Music]
all right louis so
let's finish this oh my god they're
actually gonna fight oh
face us
bow
face each other
bow
this is not the way
no
doing this
wow it's nuts
miguel wants daniel sam wants johnny
ready
oh
[Music]
all he has to do is score one more point
and larusso is the winner
don't let him get to you scores two on
the russo
ready
[Music]
holy [ __ ] there's a ferocity
that was sick
of course 2-2
next point wins
thank you samantha they're going to
knock each other out
i'm so nervous
they tied are you sure are you sure
check the replay i was wondering how
they could tie i think i said that out
loud earlier
[Laughter]
through another angle there is no other
english
don't you guys have another phone oh no
[ __ ] [ __ ] eli what happened
[Music]
who did this hmm
cobra guy it doesn't matter how many
times we stand up to cobra kai if we
don't strike back they're gonna keep
coming at us and you're worried about my
influence on your kids
you know you don't have to worry about
it anymore
cause we're done god damn it just eagle
fangs let's go
oh no
me hoggy does let's go
[Music]
oh guys
[Music]
bring them together miguel
[Music]
i have sad nipple chills
nipple tears
that's a real pain in the ass guys
you're done stop the episode guys it's
not going to play automatically
battle of perspectives radon and
kobrakai then johnny who will win
so crazy man
you know for sure they're not going to
come back together they're not
definitely not a thousand percent that
will come back together we're gonna have
four main plot lines that we have
it's gonna be chaos at the end yeah
i mean you'd expect them to not have a
work at a certain point but i love that
they by bringing back terry silver that
is the final thrust for them to
ultimately go their separate ways where
it's like it provokes their ego so much
and their arrogance of what the right
direction is to the point where it puts
them at their final odds with one
another
and you know it's like when they're
arguing you do go back and forth because
it's like guys the whole point is to not
be black and white about the situation
the point is that
sometimes we're yours doing works it's
sometimes when you're doing works but
they're both feel so desperate
in what is right
that it's like paul it's like become a
martial arts game of politics between
the two of them and it's really well
written if i was really intense at the
end and i love just how they deal with
perspective so much so that with the
even with the flashbacks like you're
seeing the moments that johnny's when
he's doing his training montage
and he's remembering like all the times
he felt danny picked on him and then
they kind of go back to those same
memories and it's the moments when
johnny who he felt johnny's like wow
they both just remember this [ __ ] so
differently
and uh it's really fascinating to see
how they do it and i like the there's
just so much about like father sons
children's daughters
you know kids there's so much about them
and how you know like robbie's at cobra
kai mcgill's
learning a little more to miyagido sam's
converting a little bit more to eagle
fang and it's really interesting
watching the the influences around and
when really it's like you guys need to
have a mature conversation and that's
why i think amanda is such a breath of
fresh air as like the audience cipher to
always show up and just have this look
of like this is ridiculous every single
time
damn diggity i've said all i need to say
did it
well done brevity was over it's the soul
of encapsulating everything you need to
say in a short amount of time equating
to a nice micro sized dose of words
end of quote
i couldn't and true take it away what
the hell do i say after that i said just
two minutes of stuff
shorts shortened to short and sweet i
agree i agree with everything you were
saying and i like how we expanded upon
from the last episode were you know
having the influence of the teachings on
each of their students and just seeing
the conflict that arise and i love that
you pointed out that terry silver is
that final thrust that just pushed them
apart because you'd see daniel's
obviously not
in the mind of critical thinking anymore
he's uh because of all the terrible
memories that he had from part three and
i really i think though my favorite part
of this whole episode was that
conversation that terry had and uh
crease at the restaurant that was just
to see uh thomasin griffith's acting
prowess i mean that dude just has a
presence to him and he's just so
freaking good and they're just both such
good manipulators that i mean
you kind of find yourself rooting for
them even though you're really not but i
mean they're just so good and i just
seeing their chemistry and their
interactions is just priceless i love it
uh do you think terry's manipulating
crease
in in certain aspects i mean he did get
him to stop you know i mean even though
he's understanding the plan
not making him uh being jealous of him
like taking over the students anymore so
i mean he knows how to get under creases
uh you know uh head and all that too
because obviously they they fought
together in vietnam and they i mean they
started cobra kai together and they have
a history so you know it's it's it's
interesting to watch their interactions
but uh i think terry's really good at
appearing like he means well
you know i think i think that's what
that scene does so good is like i can't
tell if you're just
looking out for what you believe
or if you actually do
kind of care about crease right now
because parts of it do make sense it's
like no no don't just look at the
minutia of like oh you know they they
struck out physically against us look at
the bigger picture which is like a
decent message of like you have the
greatest asset of all in the sort of
mind game and i think that's a nice
illustration of both of them is crease
has the very physical
uh tactics whereas terry silver in a lot
of ways is all about the mind game and
it's really cool the way that they
juxtapose the two teams because yeah you
have
crease and terry silver kind of
succeeding it did really very much
succeeding at what johnny and danny are
trying to do but you can see how their
parts really match whereas johnny and
danny are the sort of disarray
of
trying to bring their ideologies and
clarify them to themselves and then each
other
you know and so
yeah i i love just the juxtaposition of
their split versus the fortification of
crease and silver in this and the way
too that like they're really good at
making all these things feel of the
character motivations it makes sense how
johnny and danny would get very riled
because these are people who like in
their youth and their sort of core
experiences really affected them in ways
that they're still dealing with and all
that [ __ ] about like let the past go you
know don't even think about that like
they're so mired in it
um and even with the kids it's like you
know you can see some of that coming for
dramatic weight but it's like yeah you
even that felt natural too of like well
yeah of course
sam is going to want to kind of
gravitate toward what she hasn't always
grown up inside of and miguel is going
to want to gravitate away from his home
base you know as these things happen and
yeah
it's it's great because it gives you
like the cheese you want of like oh
danny versus johnny but also like really
conscientiously
easter eggs easter eggs all right uh
just off the top of my head what i
remembered uh during the training
montage when johnny's running we see a
guy kicking a soccer ball on his knee
and leg obviously we saw daniel do that
in the first film when he was hitting on
alley uh we do get to see a deleted
scene from karate kid the first karate
kid film with the blueberry saying
that's uh after daniel buys lunch for
him and ally we never obviously got to
see that in the first film but they did
talk about that in season three uh when
they were talking to ali and having that
at the encino country club they talked
about the blueberry scene i remember
when they mentioned i was like oh that
is the blueberry deleted scene uh then
also too we get terry silver saying i
can teach you the three ds he said this
to daniel larusso in uh karate kid part
three
i believe some of the punches uh in that
final fight were very reminiscent uh
from the their fight in the original
film and also two in the spot where
daniel got hit that's where miyagi taped
up his ribs in that same exact spot the
first film as well uh and yeah that's
all i got right now at the top of my
head what about you guys did you guys
notice anything oh man they referenced
highlander at the beginning
which came out in what year good 86.
hell's yeah [ __ ] you actually knew that
can be only one uh what's surprising to
me about you guys
i left you an opportunity oh no and no
one said nothing what did we do wrong
mohawk
oh
or like
no hawk
yes
and also in this episode i thought we
got a very interesting perspective of
how a phone actually breaks as opposed
to falling on greg
yeah they even
they sold they saw uh you know in
editing like that doesn't make sense
we're gonna have someone step on this
one
yeah thank you for bringing that back
andrew you got it that's what i'm here
for
hawk has suffered the greatest
consequence he just dyed his hair he's
been dishonored girl character what's
her name moon moon was like damn you're
looking kind of great with the purple
and what it means yeah crown chakra i
think that's what she said yeah so
you know he derives so much of his
identity and confidence from that and
then you know he's all about hawks and
everywhere the hot dad dude the mohawk
he's got a tomahawk at home
big howard hawks big fan of hawkeye the
show
and another favorite movie black hawk
down i call it really into that man
every time he orders pizza he orders it
as mike
oh my gosh
and uh yeah it's all about the hawk and
now to have that i don't know why i just
didn't finish shaving his head yeah at
that point i'm like you know that's not
gonna i've seen cyberpunk movies where
they try to pull that hairstyle off and
it's it's not the coolest hairstyle i'm
just saying like he went and walked all
that way just to be like look what the
dude was taking a photo
text it to everybody to sit then
everyone will receive it and laugh and
that's not what you want
maybe i felt really bad for him in that
moment
i i kind of feel like there was so much
attention to hawk in the third season
and just how he just went down such like
the biggest [ __ ] path with
little teases
of
you know his to him have a a
a change of heart again
and it seems like they've been putting
him down the punishment route here
but it's kind of been uh
feel a little bit like an afterthought
honestly he could be more of a character
for real it's like yeah the first
episode set it up in a way where it
seemed like it would go down like we're
really gonna show watching like kind of
grow
like an earn his way back to
the friendships and stuff but the
uh but then it's like you see that
moment on the first episode he has the
idea for the bat for the um the bridge
okay when bridge yes
wow
that's amazing
all these years and still impresses me
the okinawan bridge
and he's like
he's bullying kenny
that felt a little bit old
a missed opportunity yeah
to respond maybe a little bit
differently and and to make a bigger
choice as the show i mean i guess it
would open up more
yeah you know gray area but
even to have him maybe intervene on the
two kids are trying to pick on kenny or
something yeah it's true yeah i don't
know
i don't really have a closing thought on
that i would just say that we'll see how
this goes because
nuance going guys
fly like a hawk to that subscribe button
should become a superject today also hey
let's do a paper
andrew hayes you have been selected by
the great and wonderful andrew gordon
you both have so much in common too
so much of the time when i talk with you
andrew i think of andrew gordon i'm like
so much useless info stored in that
noggin of yours you both have such an
interesting amount of unique energy
you're both ferocious
you both look like wolverine you're both
four foot three that's right if you got
both on top of each other and wore a
trench coat you could get into an
r-rated movie you both are really into
locksmithing types of deals andrew's
always talking about working on them
security keys and i just picked a lock
on my way in i don't know who the shouts
more confusing for
you
or the audience yeah yeah but either way
andrew you've been pledged to our page
since 2017 my god we're gonna have to do
something on your fifth anniversary
we gotta celebrate man we're gonna make
a shout out a whole video just shout out
five years you've been with us in five
years you've been coming up with
something to say once a month for you
i love you for it man don't ever leave
you sexy son of a [ __ ]
he's a better andrew you haven't been
pledged for us ever sorry did you pledge
to me do you have something to pledge to
do no i don't but still it shouldn't
stop i pledge my loyalty man i vouch for
you for daisy donnie brock
[Music]
you